[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every student who's an admitted freshmen
at Hillsdale College we send them a copy
of Aristotle's ethics that's a
frightening thing to do everybody knows
that there's something a little
complicated right I brought my toy
Aristotle here this morning so you can
see how friendly he is the reason to do
it is we all have a common problem
everybody has one problem how do you
live well and we're in charge of that we
human beings in our well-being our
happiness depends upon how we do that
and then I come here and ethics is the
first great book written about that
subject and in my belief the best book
ever written
Aristotle begins with a very dramatic
statement and in the first sentence of
the ethics he says that every action and
every choice and every inquiry and every
thing we make we seem to make for some
good if you just start with this
question what's good and how do I be
that that's what the subject of ethics
is about
morning kiddies how you doing so this is
a class about ethics what is that the
study of human character what one ought
to do what do we mean by character the
recurrent habits of action that you
follow through in your life it mean
habits
it's the steady state of its formed
throughout habits so you have the steady
state through which you'll act in a
particular way because of the kind of
character you have so that's something
to mark down before we're done we need
to figure out what we mean by a steady
state and we need to figure out how you
get one I argue that ethics is the study
of how best to live you know what's you
know what's going to dominate your
careers
insofar as the domination is in your
power your character
it'll be overwhelmingly important the
credentials matter right at the
beginning but then human being fully at
work reveals itself and the good ones
get promoted in any just situation so it
matters what you are very much why is it
ethics important because we're trying to
figure out how to be good good good is
important and that we're going to find
out that it's a really commanding word
it's a beautiful word we're going to
learn what the word beautiful means too
so ethics is ethics trying to figure out
how to be good no it's becoming good
being good and then being good give me
another definition of that word one of
ethics yeah I would say develop
development of your character character
big word big word lots of disputes in
America today about character
we're not gonna make any topical
references except that one very vague
illusion but character comes from a
Greek word you're the one who knows
Greek do you know Greek the Greek word
caressing mark yeah mark H engrave
tattoo you know not paint on the surface
dig in right character is dug in
something deep in us and I if we do our
work well everybody who watches this is
going to know how you do that and what
you're like if you do it well it's what
Steven said down there he said learning
how to be good and that is the whole
question we almost never asked that
question today we introduced the young
to learning the word education means
lead forth we leave off forth and that
means we introduce the young to
education with an invitation for them to
become whatever they want to be but you
know they could become ostriches maybe
but they wouldn't be very good at that
and for a reason that we're going to
study in this class
it's the reason ethics is a big subject
it is the first subject and this is the
first book ever written about it and I
will tell you back in the Paleolithic
era when I was in graduate school in the
first class I had with the great man he
called this one of the greatest books
ever written so somebody read the first
sentence what does it say every art and
every inquiry and likewise every action
and choice seems to aim at some good and
hence it has been beautifully said but
the good is that at which all things aim
now look at the nouns in that sentence
and aren't they interesting they're all
fundamental words what is art me
technical knowledge yeah yeah a craft
something bank so you said the word
technical and the Greek word is Tecna
that's making it means it doesn't mean
like in the background is Raphael's
School of Athens right that's fine art
that's high art but it has in common
with whoever made that glass right there
that it was produced it was made it was
designed and executed according to skill
and with the purpose in mind and the
first claim is that every time we do
that we aim at some good isn't it
interesting that word good we're gonna
have to figure out what that means
what's an inquiry just a question it
says something more than a question
isn't it the word is a method else in
Greek and a method in other words
undertake it right it's just you know
heck I wonder what's going to happen
tomorrow and then you go on about your
life that's not an inquiry right we're
going to find out what ethics is this is
an inquiry and also remember we're going
to encounter in book 1 Aristotle saying
the reason this book is to be read is to
become good this is an urgent inquiry
and this inquiry like every other he
says Eames it's some good action what's
that word ok I don't actually know yeah
praxis you don't knows Greek somebody
here was spouting Greek last time yeah
yeah so praxis you know what that means
yeah it's like doing it yeah we get
practice practical from it practice so
every action we take right every time we
make something every time we inquire
about something every time we act and
then the last is choice what's choice
picking between alternatives that's
right
and that word is pro heresies and that's
one of the most important words in the
ethics in fact they're all very
important words but if you had to pick
one of these words that word is crucial
because choice is at the center of the
building of character in this word
choice is found the basis of human
freedom because it's not just that
you're free to choose it's also that
your choices matter very much and they
make you what you are human beings we're
going to discover faced obstacles and
the virtues are the good confrontation
and tackling of those are obstacles and
if you do that it will change you and
make you better
you can become awesome start today and
and it's so another thing is this is the
greatest self-help book ever written so
they all seemed aim at some good and
we're gonna get a full definition of
that word next time but what what does
it mean provisionally right now well I
thought it was interesting that he
qualifies it as some good and not good
so I guess he's introducing some
ambiguity saying well there might be
more than one thing that is good and
we're gonna try to find out a murder in
action yes every murder aims at some
good that's the claim right yeah I do
you think that's true
at a perceived good someone thinks that
committing a murder will be good in the
end I think at least in the great
majority of cases and a real good I'll
tell you why there's a really great
television news report does that sound
like an oxymoron something that's a
contradiction in terms
it was interviews in a Texas
maximum-security prison and here were
their claims almost all of the claims
were I didn't do it I did it because and
what follows because it's always some
good I needed money
this person harmed me or something dear
to me then ex culpa Tory factors yeah a
lot of people did worse and didn't get
as bad a sentence as I got see they were
all talking about justice and the good
it's very rare in fact it's a sign of
insanity if somebody says I killed him
and I did it because I'd love to kill
maybe people are moved by that but they
hardly ever say that this says
unavoidably you're aiming for something
that you claim is good yeah one so I get
the distinction then is between aiming
at something that's good and the action
itself being good because perhaps we can
say that the murder itself wasn't a good
thing to do even if it was a murder sure
but you know just if you just abstract
from the murder from the moral
implication of it somebody said a bomb
with a purpose to kill Adolf Hitler
right was that good or put it more
directly George Patton wanted nothing
more than to get to Berlin first and
personally shoot Adolf Hitler that's
what he thought he was made for would
that be a murder yes yes
I shouldn't do that you should you
should yeah remember all of these four
kinds of actions which describe every
voluntary human action have a moral
caste that is the rightness or wrongness
of them is in question and do you see
about this confusion that there's some
good well there are many Goods and we're
gonna find out they're arranged in a
hierarchy these many Goods and it's a
little confusing to know which one to be
pursuing now if you think for a minute
what's going on in your mind
minute by minute day by day what must
what's the big thing in most days aren't
you trying to figure out what to do look
young and handsome and so the joys of
youth are available to you stay up all
night play or study you can do it night
after night and then you start looking
like a scene from The Walking Dead which
is what finals are like around here and
but but all that calls to you because
it's good and then dang it you need to
read these books right and those are
both good things and one of them calls
louder sometimes but that doesn't mean
that the relationship between the two
things alters and that's a choice and
the claim is every time you make a
choice it places a mark on your soul and
it makes you what you are and nobody
makes them all perfect anybody who's
determined to make them well every day
and having failed some that day start
again in the morning those people become
good and will find out not only good
also happy which is what we all want to
be more than anything else and happy
doesn't mean in this book we're gonna
get to it it doesn't mean feel good
about yourself
and have a pleasant outlook on the day
it doesn't mean just lifting your face
up to the sunshine and seeing it warm
when you're up here in Michigan and it's
kind of cold it it those are those are
pleasures and pleasures can be bad for
you or they can be good for you it
depends on your character
okay now enhance somebody read from
there and hence it has been beautifully
said that the good is that at which all
things am but a certain difference is
apparent among okay no too far guilt
okay
feels very guilty precocious he's ready
to do the whole book right now but think
about that that second clause seemed aim
at some good beautifully said that the
good is that at which all things aim
those are different aren't they if good
means for a provisional explanation will
use the term good to mean a thing being
fully what it is that's a good glass I
don't think it's a great one not to my
taste anyway but it's fine it functions
if you drilled a hole in the bottom of
it wouldn't be a good glass any more I
like to use water bottles you know the
ubiquitous kind of things right because
if you cut the bottom off of them then
they're not a good water bottle anymore
but if you turn it upside down take the
top off they turn into a funnel so they
had the being of the water pond and that
made them a good water bottle and then
they lost the being of the water bottle
but in that particular case they gained
the being of the funnel and they could
be a good funnel I thought of that
because when I'm talking there's usually
a water bottle around and I'm looking
for something to illustrate the point
with and it turns out those are really
good so beautiful what does that mean
yeah that which is perfected of being
yeah and see Isaac here what year you in
junior he's a junior and he's precocious
too so he has a philosophic turn
and so he's going to use technical
phrases I'm gonna make them explain what
they are
so being means what well that which is
that which is not is not yeah that which
do you write use that expression when
you're right I'm an English major
No
so the being of a thing is just what it
is right in Aristotle the being of a
thing is just what it is now that makes
it good by the way if it is that thing
it's good if it's a soil they're broken
or damaged one or distorted one it's not
a good one anymore one made the very
good point that he says that every
action thought and everything every
voluntary thing we do seems to emit some
good and then it has been beautifully
said that every action aims at the good
right now I will tell you that in my
graduate student class we spent six
weeks on that sense and it was worth it
now so just think of that the contrast
right there's a contrast between good
and beautiful and there's a contrast
between some and thee and the
implication is going to be that the
goods are arranged in a hierarchy so
somebody read on but a certain
difference is apparent among ends since
some are ways of being at work while
others are certain kinds of works
produced over and above the being at
work being at work what does that mean
what why does he use that this is by the
way an idiosyncratic translation I like
it and he uses being at work to
emphasize the fact that Aristotle uses
that word for being in a kind of a
technical way and it means active
radiating pulsing with its existence
Aristotle doesn't see that that is inert
that's busy being a glass right now so
that's why I uses that one of the
reasons why I use that so go ahead
and in those cases in which there are
ends of any kind
beyond the actions the works produced
are by nature better things than the
activities okay let's stop about that
but a certain difference is apparent
among ends what're ends purposes right
it's a very important word in Aristotle
Tilos we get telescope from it something
out distant that you can see right and
ends are what you aim for but you're
after right yeah we don't and since
there are many actions and arts and
kinds of knowledge the ends also turn
out to be many of medical knowledge the
end is health of shipbuilding skill it
is about a strategic art it is victory
of household management it is wealth but
in as many such pursuits as are under
someone capacity in the way that bridle
making and all the other skills involved
with implements pertaining to horses
come under horsemanship well this and
every action pertaining to war come
under strategic art and in the same way
other pursuits are under other
capacities in all of them the ends of
all the master arts are more worthy of
choice than are the ends of the pursuits
that come under them okay so let's
unpack that so somebody makes a bridle
why do they do it
tread the horse well they want the
bridle why do they want the bridle sure
outdoors bridle making bridle
horsemanship what's that good for
in the Greek world cavalry an urgent
good right you need that or you can lose
everything and the ultimate thing then
that this light that this chain of
things aims for is victory and victory
is a different kind of thing than the
others because you always want it and
you're always diminished without it
whereas you know bridle making is often
an annoyance and you can certainly have
too many bridles but victory you just
need that thing and he mentioned the
medical art right and it's a
his health health is like victory you
need that thing
each of these things takes its dignity
from the step above it and from all the
steps above it and that means the higher
good that it serves even a small
beginning point thing the greater the
dignity it has so we're gonna find out
that the things that can make you happy
because that's the highest human good
according to Aristotle it means to live
beautifully which is the hi beautiful is
the highest form of the good and that's
a pagan thought but it's not entirely
different from the Christian thought of
beatitude see God finally and that would
be seeing a complete and ultimate
perfection person who put that argument
together best is probably Thomas Aquinas
who wrote a long commentary on this book
that's very worth reading okay in the
first sentence all of our actions are
directed at some good and it's beautiful
to say that all of them taken together
aim it Z good and then it's introduced a
hierarchy of the goods and you see how
in that twenty lines or whatever it is
you start learning to look at the
universe vertically things point up and
one of the things about reading this
book is you have to learn to look up
it's not young people today are sort of
taught this way if you sort of drew a
picture of how they're taught they think
that there are many universes and they
stand at the center of one of them CS
Lewis like to make the point that back
in the day when we criticize everybody
for being such fools they thought the
earth was the center of the universe and
see as Lewis a very learned man points
out in in one of his academic works the
discarded image is the title of the
briefest version of that academic work
he points out that that's not what they
thought in the ancient in the medieval
world they thought we were at the bottom
of the universe
with that we were standing down the
bottom looking up at a great height
skyscrapers the bottom of the Grand
Canyon and that you know that's not
hubris that's reverence that reverence
is contained in this sentence within the
limit but this is an inquiry we're
supposed to find out supposed to get to
the truth of the matter that's what
we're here to do
[Music]